again I'd have to say
the first thing everyone should ask
themselves is what does it mean to be
realistic and as realistic the same
thing as resigning the second thing is
to acknowledge that more is possible in
your life that almost anybody ever told
you and the third is to think about the
following thought experiment which was
brought up by Conte it's uh it's I find
it very helpful Comte indiscreet terms
this was the 18th century he asks us to
imagine a man who cannot resist says he
can't resist temptation every time he
walks by a certain house I mean it's a
brothel but if you put a gallows in
front of the brothel and he knew that he
would going to be hung the minute he
walked out he would find that he could
resist temptation very well so we all
agree that love of life Trump's every
other physical desire that you have
whether it's for sex or food or whatever
form of pleasure doesn't for you love of
life is the basis of every other
pleasure then Kahn says imagine the same
man is asked to sign a letter condemning
an innocent person to death and he's
threatened by an unjust tyrant with
death himself unless he cooperates and
the innocent man's death and what Kant
says is none of us know what we would do
in that situation most of us would
probably be cowards but all of us know
what we should do and all of us
therefore know that we would be free to
do the right thing and to refuse to
participate in injustice even if it
would cost our own lives and I think
furthermore I think everybody can
perform that experiment I've tried it
out on a number of people I think
furthermore that everybody has one hero
either in real life or in fiction who
they would like to be in at least one
moment you may think you can't live up
to that person
but you have one person who you think
would act rightly in that situation and
I think we should keep those people in
mind of course hopefully being a good
person doesn't involve sacrificing your
life and in fact sometimes it's easier
to be good and rather banal and simple
ways that it is to go out in one great
heroic gesture so I think the last thing
in being a good person it's important to
remember if evil can be banal and I
think it can be goodness is also banal
too it consists in ordinary everyday
actions
you